eric fetty on the year comes into
tonight's game with a 4-6 record a 4.59
era basically a four-pitch mix sinker
cutter curveball change up he does have
a four-seam fastball padres jump on top
here in the first half fernando at third
swinging a shot up the middle caught by
trey turner throw to third back safely
is tatis
on a looping liner
up the middle turner lunges forward a
leap and makes the catch his momentum
taking him back toward the outfield had
to whirl around and try and get
something out of throw to third two out
of the inning the infield can drop back
fine play by turner
the ground ball softly towards third
base mercer
on the run and the throw not in time
ronald score
tatis in the back door from third the
padres strike first on top one nothing
two on
two down and eric hosmer ground ball
through the left side into left field a
base hit coming around from second is
machado he will score and the padres
with some two out magic take a two
nothing lead in the first inning cosmo
the base hit driving in a run
taking off for second base is hospital
getting hung up trying to score from
third and doing so
is tommy pham padres pull off the double
steal so hosmer drawing that throw and
then in the back door from third comes
fam of the padres take a three-nothing
lead chris panic on the mound for san
diego chris comes into tonight's game
with a four and six record a 5.38 era
three-pitch mix forcing fastball the
changeup and all of a sudden that
curveball is being used a lot more from
chris paddock
juan soto the all-star bounty with two
on nobody out here in the last half of
the first inning
wants soto
right fields
this ball game is tied
for the second time in nine days
juan soto hits a three run home run off
chris paddock in the first inning just
like that it's 3-3 tie ball game juan
soto ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the second half juan on the
ground up the middle and ranging his
tatis from the outfield grasses throw in
time
not a play by fernando
back up the middle able to pick it and
from shallow center throws out josh bell
at first this one lying down the right
field line and fair
jordy mercer is gonna turn for extra
bases
a two out double
for the nationals third baseman
and they're not done with chris paddock
in the first inning just yet oh and two
rivera swings and misses strike three
and paddock ends the first the very same
way that fetty did with a strikeout of
the number seven hitter they get three
and we'll go to the second tie to three
and the bases are loaded for jake
cronenworth with one out here in the
second here's the two two to chronoworth
and that is down the left field line for
a base hit harrison had him played well
but kind of slips as he went to pick it
up a couple of runs are going to come in
and score padres get a pair here
gronnerworth ends up at second base as
caratini and grisham cross the plate and
the padres are back in front five to
three and the bases are loaded again
one two is lined into right field big
set for hosmer becomes tatis he will
score padres take a 6-3 lead laurens
with three grand slams on his resume
high drive
in the air too deep left field for myers
and the slam diego padres around the
road in washington a grand slam and the
padres jump out to the 10-3 lead will
myers with his 11th home run of the year
oh this these are the slam diego padres
two down to sit first and jake cronin
work
breaking ball lying down the right field
line that's a fair ball headed towards
the corner tatis headed for third and
beyond they're gonna wave him around dug
out by soto tatis will score ending up
at third is jake cronenworth and the
padres taking a 11-3 lead jake
cronenworth has driven in three
swinging a high high fly ball to center
field
para
drifting back a bit and toward right
center he'll make the catch
para
records all three outs in the inning
here's eric osmer two for two
there's a liner out to right field and
it's gonna be over the head of soto
tommy pham is coming around to score the
12th padres run
and another hit for hosmer it's an extra
base hit and another rbi
12-3 padres
the 2-0 swinging a high drive straight
away center and deep grisham way back
toward the warning track angling along
the track the ball off the wall caroms
by him toward left center field harrison
racing for third grisham retrieves the
ball fires it in as harrison goes
jogging into third with a lead off
stand-up triple that one hit just to the
left of the 402 mark in dead center
field
here's the pitch swinging a ground ball
chopped to short should bring in a run
it will tatis throws on the move to
first and gets the out and jordy mercer
drives in his second run of the season
so a triple and a ground out
that's now san diego 12 in the nationals
four
two hits in game he's got a double and a
triple driven in three
fly ball headed to deep right field that
ball is back up oh it's gone
home run for jake cotterworth he is a
single shy of hitting for the cycle in
tonight's game a double in the second a
triple in the third a home run in the
fifth and the padres take a 13-4 lead
pham hosmer and myers coming up against
wonder swirl here's the two in one fan
with a big swing sends it to the air
straight away center field to deep bar
going back he is at the wall looking up
gonna go
padres have scored in all six innings of
this game and tommy pham has scored for
the fourth time today
14-4 here in the sixth
myers hits this one in the air deep down
the right field line soto back to the
corner looking up gonna go
a two-run shot for will myers will with
his second of the night and his 12th of
the season a two-run shot it is 16-4
here in the sixth homerun derby has come
back to nationals park
on the ground and through into left
field to base hit o'grady will score
coming around is grisham he'll score the
padres take an 18-4 lead
single for tatis drives in two more and
here is jake cronenworth got a double in
the second a triple in the third home
run in the fifth it's a single to
complete it ground ball softly hit left
side connor worth will reach jake
cudaworth hits for the cycle we are all
in the ground zone
infield hit to complete the cycle
tonight third cycle in franchise history
for the san diego padres belongs to jake
cronenberg
when it's going good it's going good
running goes at first here's a base hit
into left field
scoring from third base
is kim
fam with an rbi single on the padres of
19 runs on top 19-4
juan soto who against the padres this
year is seven for 16 with three homers
and eight rbis the 3-1 long drive deep
right into orbit
forget about it
second deck home run for juan soto well
the nationals fans finally have
something to cheer a multi-homer game
for juan soto
number 13.
squares this one up
right field
gerardo parra three run shot a four spot
for the nationals here in the sixth and
the padres have runners at the corners
with two down
and liner into center field make it
seven
as in from third comes fam but rbi
single on the padres making an even 20
runs
on top 20 to eight in this one and a big
night for will myers
liner into left field
reeboks will score
meyers coming around the throw is going
to be cut off two more runs for the
padres
and they have 22 runs in this game on
top 22-8
new franchise record
and a base hit into left field
caratini is coming playword and that's
23 runs for the san diego padre 23-8
padres
that one is hit really well by jorge
mateo to deep left field why not another
home run for mateo
24-8
in the ninth inning fifth home run of
the night for the padres nationals are
not going quietly
popped up
over from first and diving to make the
catches carrottini that's the ball game
victor cartini and foul ground makes the
catch and the padres
have won game one with authority